Immigration and Customs Enforcement is
expected to follow up on a warning
president Trump made earlier this week
to round up thousands of illegal
immigrants the operation planned for at
least ten cities could begin as soon as
tomorrow Manuel Vargas says critics see
it as just another way the
administration is working to separate
families our country should be a
sanctuary for law-abiding citizens not
for criminal aliens the president
announced the raids ahead of his
twenty20 re-election launched Tuesday
tweeting that ice will begin the process
of removing the millions of illegal
aliens though not millions ice officers
do plan mass roundups targeting more
than two thousand undocumented
immigrants including families who have
been given final deportation orders the
administration has come under fire for
zero-tolerance policy which led to mass
family separations in an interview with
spanish-language Network Telemundo
Thursday the president tried to blame
the policy on his predecessor under the
Obama plan we're talking about yet no no
we're not because I'm the one that put
people together just they separated I
put a beginning did not 2800 children
were reunited with their parents in this
last year after the zero policy because
I put into getting them the
administration says the raids are
necessary to deal with the influx at the
border where 144 thousand migrants were
taken into custody just last month but
critics and targeted cities like here in
Miami fear they could lead to more
family separations for CBS this morning
Saturday and while Bojorquez Miami